so thanks to some new information that
just came out in the manga today we
finally know some new details about the
quirks of previous WOM for all users and
while my BAC ago being the second user
theory hasn't been proven just yet
trust me guys it's coming ok maybe not
I'm gonna break down the new info
regarding their quirks and their hero
names and then I'll explain exactly what
that means for the future and if you
only watch the anime and don't want to
know any spoilers then just check out
this interview I did with Mario's voice
actor instead as the video you're
currently watching will be spoiler
central but without further ado let's
get into it so way back in the manga we
saw all the vestiges of the previous
users of one for all but at that point
we didn't know any of their quirks
excluding all my because we know he was
quote cursed as hell but thanks to this
latest chapter we found out that the
bored guy right here is the fifth user
of one for all and his hero name is
lariat pretty punchy name I gotta say
and as most of you already know his
quirk is called black whip essentially
it's just a massive black energy that
can be controlled by the user at will
and it can be used to capture enemies or
swing objects around or even just fling
yourself around town like Spider Man in
the least we see Larry at doing just
that as he swings across a building with
black whip in his right hand and in his
left hand he has some more black whip
ready to go all might says that black
whip isn't particularly strong but from
this pick it looks pretty strong to me
and we've also seen deque who use it to
hold up three cars simultaneously which
just shows it's incredible level of
strength but obviously this is likely
because it's been built up over time
inside one for all so yeah while a lot
of you may already have known this guy's
quirk we at least got confirmation that
he's the fifth user of one for all and
what his hero name is and for those of
you that care his legal name is Manawa
die Goro with his last name containing
the kanji for fifth which is kind of
following the same scheme as the three
users we already knew about and the next
bit of information we find out is
related to all mice Master nana shamora
now to me it's kind of crazy that we're
only finding out about her quirk in
Chapter 257 but finally finally finally
we know what it is essentially it's the
power of levitation which is something
that we've definitely seen all for one
use which makes me kind of think that
maybe he harvested it from her dead body
after he killed her that would be pretty
dark horikoshi
not much else is elaborated on the quark
besides this but when I put my
speculation glasses on there's a lot we
can gather from this if you guys
remember another levitation quote that
we're aware of in this series is the one
belonging to Dec whose mom I think it
was the first episode but she
demonstrated that she had the power to
levitate small objects towards her and
then after that if you remember when all
my met tech who's one for the first time
he noted that she reminded him of his
master horikoshi doesn't waste panels
okay like there's a reason all might
said that and now it's really got me
thinking because they're quirks are a
bit similar I don't want to go too hard
into the theories here but what if they
are related because if they are related
then by definition that means Shigure
Aki and Deku are related because Nana
shamora is Rocky's grandmother and
added on to this when you compare how
similar Deku and shigaraki both looked
his children grow like there's something
going on here okay but anyway similar to
black whip this levitation power would
have increased in strength over time as
it was being built up inside one for all
so what that means for Deku is that when
he accesses this levitation quirk in the
future it will likely be better than
simply being able to float around hell I
reckon once he masters this thing he'll
basically be able to fly around like
Superman which kind of leads to another
question how is that I'm gonna keep
explaining all these new quirks that
he's getting like explaining black whip
was a stretch but the fact that he'll
now be able to fly at some point would
just raise too many eyebrows ba guys
that's all the new information that we
have on the previous users from this
chapter we've learned about Nana she
Morris quark and we also learned what
the name of the bald user of one for all
is I have a longer video planned for
this weekend and as long as my laptop
doesn't explode I'll see you then please
subscribe and peace out